un panorama desolador así lucen las
icónicas playas de Miraflores en Lima
las cuales fueron cerradas a los
bañistas debido a un brote de gripe
aviar que deja al menos a 13.000 aves
muertas principalmente Pelícanos Durante
los próximos días las autoridades
recogerán los cadáveres infectados para
evitar el aumento en la propagación del
virus
restringir el acceso de veraneantes pero
lo deportistas pueden hacer su deporte
se llama malecón y los surfistas pueden
ingresar al mar porque no tienen
contacto con la arena no o con la
piedras el virus detectado la variante
h5n1 hace que las aves pierdan
coordinación no puedan volar y que sus
cuellos se doblen el pasado 30 de
noviembre Pero había declarado alerta
nacional durante 90 días prohibiendo la
movilización de aves domésticas sin
certificados y la cancelación de ferias
o eventos de gallos las autoridades han
tranquilizado a la población tras
asegurar que el consumo de productos
avícolas como el pollo pavo huevos entre
otros no suponen un riesgo de contagio
para los humanos Aunque pidieron hacer
un seguimiento riguroso es bonita y que
todos están alertados por eso es que no
quieren que se pueda diseminar a las
granjas no de Corral porque una vez que
se edifique un individuo En una granja
de coral terminan
sacrificando al grupo no a toda esta
este lote de aves para que no se
disemine porque este virus es altamente
contagioso se espera que más playas sean
cerradas en Lima así como en los
departamentos costeros de tumbes y
moquegua los más afectados por este
brote